this is a whole different level to
anything we've seen before they're
wearing super advanced masks much nearer
to a gas mask than we normally see our
hospital staff wearing their thick
waterproof suits
means the doctors and nurses are sealed
in this Naples Infectious Diseases
hospital now only treats Kovac 19
patients incredibly so far at least not
a single member of the Medical Teams has
been affected it can be done you just
have to have the right gear and follow
the right protocols there's a rush on
here the patient inside is deteriorating
fast a nurse prepares an injection
outside the treatment room he never goes
inside communicating through windows to
colleagues with the patient and they
never come outside during crisis moments
and this is one when it's ready the
medicine is passed through a compartment
door remember he's not been inside and
hasn't touched anyone or anything but he
immediately removes his gloves and
scrubs down this is an absolute constant
it's a hospital trust that is dependent
upon all of the hospitals working
together because the capacity is already
pretty much full and they just accept
that if it gets worse and we'll just
have to deal with it but nobody's really
sure how and the numbers are rising as
though dad's in that again critically
they're getting younger no doubt about
it here they're saying it doesn't make
any difference if you're young or you're
old you're going to get it the lack
between the epidemic sweeping through
northern Italy and overwhelming the
healthcare system there before
progressing to the South gave this
hospital precious time to prepare it is
the exception in the south it was
already the most advanced Hospital what
is really striking here is that the
rules of separating infected
environments and the clean areas are
followed by everyone but armed security
man every connecting corridor in case
anyone forgets were moved back and the
corridors locked down as a new patient
is brought in this happens every time
preparation is the key to stopping the
virus preparation and equipment
is that speed with which things were
organized significant as a factor in
controlling the disease yes the
hospital's organized the first first
thing to do in this kind of hospital is
a doctor fiorentino and I was organizing
this to this to work and it's very very
important to support the discreet and so
on to organize our address i undress I
put a doctor or nurse in the room I'll
put your mask on it's a very important
and also you have to have the right
equipment yeah yeah we fight for we
fight for but however now we're this is
a sub intensive care unit
the patients are either recovering will
haven't deteriorated yet the same
separation rules apply the red and white
line cannot be crossed clean area nurses
and doctors assess infected area staff
across the line they keep the two
absolutely separate because in other
hospitals it's it was too chaos I got a
number of infections yeah very high yes
nothing
cross the world as the pandemic spreads
we're seeing the number of infected and
dying jump every day health workers are
right on the front line and they're
succumbing to the illness every day as
well perhaps though it doesn't have to
be inevitable it isn't here but they do
have the kit they don't just hope still
Ramsey Sky News Naples